Jeff sessions was president Trump's
attorney-general he's running to
re-enter the United States Senate he
recently made this reasonable such
suggestion how about a nationwide
moratorium on immigration until
America's unemployment rate has
recovered from this disaster Jeff
Sessions joins us tonight senator thanks
so much for coming on thank you so tell
us your proposal I want to make sure I
didn't miss state it well we have about
1.4 million people that come to this
country every year
to take jobs we just announced today
five million more people on the
unemployment roll what that 22 million
now there is no doubt it is in the
interest of the United States of America
to make sure that we get every one of
those unemployed Americans the jobs
first
I mean it's psychologically devastating
to a person not to have work it
undermines their well-being and family
but in addition we have to help them
financially if they're unemployed
whether it's Medicaid Medicare food
stamps unemployment insurance so why
bring in foreign workers to take those
jobs when we should do everything
possible as you suggested to get
American workers that are unemployed in
those jobs that is such an obvious point
and I should note that you're employing
the most basic economic principle of all
supply and demand a tighter labor market
means higher wages who could possibly
object to that and do most Americans
agree with you do you think well I think
the most Americans do agree with me I
think the polls are almost 90% that if
there's a choice between who should get
a job
the Americans should get the job over a
foreigner give me a break
how simple is that who do we owe our
responsibility to as government and
public officials it's to the American
people first so that is absolutely true
and if we do this thing right we can
minimize the number of people that are
prolonged in unemployment but it's a
scary time it is very scary and we need
to be very alert to the dangers think
about a college
graduate today in May will be graduating
what kind of prospects do they have we
have almost 500 thousand tech workers
that come to America can we figure out a
way to make sure that our kids with
maybe college debts get those jobs first
before we bring in foreigners that's
it's just the nature of the world today
we need to protect our own it's the
rational moral responsible thing to do
well this could be a long answer we only
have a minute left but I have to ask you
since you worked in government for
decades if if close to 90 percent of the
public wants something to happen and it
never happens going for many years is
this really a democracy you are asking a
fundamental question this is the time
that this issue and and others like it
are really raised to the level that the
American people understand the issue and
it's not done surreptitiously under the
table by establishment politicians on
but both parties often supported by the
low wage agenda on the some of the
corporate powers-that-be then you can
win that's how I defeated led to fight
to defeat the immigration bills it took
a long time but once the American people
understood the bogus nough stay turned
against them and the politicians did but
until they really understood the nature
of it it was on the pathway to passage
this is a real political question of
importance for America people like
yourself do help keep the American
people informed we're trying on this one
for sure senator sessions great to see
you thank you very much thank you